hey guys it's Justine and today of
hangover oh no we just did a really fun
video on her channel trying Japanese
beauty and health products I ordered a
bunch from Japan and it was really silly
it was pretty crazy and of course over
here we're playing a really interesting
game it's called pop that pick what up
that pig move that boss for you yeah I
well cuz I was like trying to make it
sound like Extreme Makeover like move
and you want to pop the pig in this game
do you I don't know a bunch about this I
have never played it but I read the box
and it's a good thing you want to make
his little pants open here's such a
happy full belly that he's like you know
your pants seem like you need to loosen
your pants after a good full meet like
that's me you got rid of the stretch
it's a good base mm-hmm that's like what
we're doing with the pig like look look
at the size of the box you got his tea
in his little pants it's super cute he's
like oh yeah so I saw this I was like I
think this will be fun so let's open it
up and take a peek at what we've got
looks fun fit for us it's great agents
what toran up so we're in the queer
I get ink we can handle this whoa whoa
whoa oh my gosh is this cute this is so
cute oh no question Jesse yes does he
have a name
or do we name them oh dear does he have
the name no II just they just keep
calling him a pig do you want to name
him I was gonna say some like Chef
Boyardee you like chef piggery is that
okay that sounds good okay Sam chef
boyardee we're gonna go with Chef figuri
so piggery
he's real sweet so the object feed the
hamburger until his belly pops to place
all the hamburgers but the numbers
facedown on the table clothes the best
and belt and push his arms out until
they click each time you push down on
his head his belly grows on the bottom
of the hamburger you will find a number
from 1 to 4 insert the hamburger all the
way into the pigs mouth using two hands
one on top of the other push down on his
head the number of times indicated on
the Hamburg
until you hear a click so we roll the
die and then we put the food in his
mouth you are clearly younger sweet of
the under goes okay okay here we go here
we go
give me a really good number of color I
don't know however you don't get to do
anything oh wow I'm not taking you to
Vegas
this is not off to a good start weird
jock won at the craps table together
this is off to a great start
Oh purple so which purple one you want
to pick is that purple
yeah that's purple alright so I've got
one so push it in there and then push
down his head once one okay good job
good job
Oh piggy piggy this is like cooking when
she gets treats I gave her a little
treat and I'm like oh here we go
okay my Luck's changing okay I'll
pretend we just went to Vegas we're
hitting the floor I'm doing something
with dice I don't know how to do it oh
you again get away from my craps table
girl can you believe I will lose all of
our money this is a really good sign
maybe you're like really lucky or really
unlucky oh alright I'm a bit off on you
now we're definitely going to Vegas
together okay here we go
this is gonna change it how this is
changing everything okay sir Jesse this
is probably a cheating dice I think this
is a weighted dice I've heard about
these that weight them so you lose
purple again cheering those I'm
a little suspicious as well okay coming
near you have to click one cue okay here
you go good let's get a little belt on
piggy piggy piggy Oh can't you see
thank you thank you yes okay yellow
Donuts its 303 let's see sunny as I got
what is it chef boy Pig Rd chef fish a
degree Chuck yeah yeah needs a little
chef piggery oh alright man 3 1 2 3
that'd be really funny but nothing's
actually out it never never pops never
pops this little pants don't pop ever
yellow yellow again - I got you - pigs
boom cute no I'm getting really nervous
me too okay I guess belly it's like
growing purple okay purple for this
might be it No 1 2 3 4 Oh dad dad it's
getting closer
Justin a green is the first green for oh
it could happen this could happen for
you girl you can win the game right here
okay point 1 - you three are close but
no cigar lucky red we're gonna do this
one or two three four nervous here Oh
one purple left three he's releasing
bees it's definitely getting bigger one
two three okay oh it's tight super tight
oh yeah he's got a full day here
definitely had Thanksgiving dinner he
did three of them he's about to have
dessert right here here we go here we go
here's some pumpkin pie we're leaning on
pie - okay so this is a little smaller
but a little dessert here you go this
little pecan pie I know it's a burger
but we're gonna pretend one - no
suspense bold another
o3o q3 oh my god it's getting so close
getting nervous
this is like a pie in the face game but
like no pie or coming after Nate yeah I
feel like it's gonna like explode it is
my mind it just may explode confetti but
that's probably now it happens but in my
mind that's what I'm excited
yellow okay one the belly booth but it
didn't stop the belly burn yellow up 400
this could be it
okay one two three four like I knew it
was gonna happen and I was still scared
okay his belly oh we got a little bloat
we needs a belly rub tickle there was a
lot of burgers could you imagine eating
that many burgers like going in and out
and you're like hey I'll take 20 burgers
that was definitely a little scarier
than I thought
look at him oh my gosh I I was like I
love this so much it's so cool and then
this is where all the burgers go in the
back I need to definitely get more games
that are made for three-year-olds we
gotta take out all the hamburgers is
there any more in here oh I hear oh you
doing in there I gotta push close the
best and push the belt and his arms
until they click though they're supposed
to click oh gosh
but his belly's firm gee you got okay
Oh God you know there's our muscles you
got I think we you've got it he's just
okay let's eat Justine Justine is just
giving you moral support is this like a
one-time beep it's not supposed to be
hope for us it might be but we need an
adult okay in all fairness the reset is
a little difficult
I can build a computer but I can't
figure out this page that isn't a
nutshell you're like I can code an
entire website
she's so smart she can code an entire
website and you can bake an entire like
house and I'll eat anything but us
putting this back together is not gonna
happen so that's that oh I pushed his
head back Oh yep it did not say that the
direction is to be fair that's it thank
you for playing this game it was like a
pop punk hey make sure you guys go check
out the video we did on Rose Channel
trying Japanese beauty problems it was
quite entertaining for sure mm-hmm
it was really silly I have never seen
half of those things no it was nuts well
make sure you go check out her Channel
and subscribe to all of the things row
down below and we will see you guys in
the next video I feel like we've got a
burger thing going on so we did the
burger mania again yeah so so fun this
oh we need another fun game this feels
like flush like it's just feels like oh
yeah yeah like skin bye
[Music]